To compute the parameter
updates of a recurrent network,
we need to backpropagate
the derivative through time,
all the way to the beginning
of the sequence.
Or in practice, more often, for
as many steps as we can afford.
All these derivatives are going to
be applied to the same parameters.
That's a lot of correlated updates
all at once, for the same weights.
This is bad for
stochastic gradient descent.
Stochastic gradient descent,
prefers to have uncorrelated updates,
to its parameters, for
the stability of the training.
This makes the math very unstable.
Either the gradients grow exponentially
and you end up with infinities.
Or they go down to zero very quickly.
And you end up not training anything.